how do you feel about the racist comment
that was made on uh
no jumper I haven't which was there yeah
it was something about us being slaves I
didn't see that okay you have to check
that one out it was with Destiny and a
few a couple other guys in this young
lady that was on there and they made
some comment that was super crazy
and uh the guy Dijon he kind of posted
it too on his uh Instagram yeah report
card yeah the report card guy yeah so
was it and Adam made the joke or was it
the other guy or uh they both made the
joke tell me something about uh you
didn't you thought I was black guy you
know I'm a black slave something along
those lines but go look at it it's kind
of ruffling
he said oh you know I thought you was
something that you were in hip-hop
you were in hip-hop and it was like oh
no I thought you was just a slave owner
that's what Adam said
you guys think you guys are I mean I
don't think Adam's racist do you guys
think he's racist no me personally right
yeah I don't no I don't think he's
racist I think that sometimes like when
I see something to defend him because I
see some of these old tweets going viral
I think white humor is like super dark
at times and mind you there's some [__]
that like was joked about that I
wouldn't joke about but I know people
but then again you still have a guy come
on like Richard Spencer and then it kind
of makes you question yourself like [__]
like why would you bring that guy all
here on this platform when you you know
you have everybody around like I don't
see him as a [__] reform
so I mean I think back to like when he
they they did Nick Fuentes you were part
of that conversation I think it would
have made sense to have a person of
color be a problem yeah a part of that
conversation I mean I watched some of it
and it seemed like a pretty like good
combo
um because I was like yeah why would
that because I just think of that dude
as a tiki torch guy you know from
Charlottesville so then I started I
watched like maybe like 20 minutes of it
when I was cleaning my office and I was
like oh this dude is like uh is he he
like turned in his racist car or some
[__] I don't know but yeah I don't know
man I think I think that kind of [__] I
think you know I think Adam obviously
wants to do more provocative content now
that is like more like on the political
fringes bro he's older bro and like you
know even like a year prior to that he
was like listen to this podcast and it
was literally like three hours about the
covet vaccine right some [__] I would
never [__] listen to in my life so I
already knew like his mind was pivoting
somewhere else like his interest is not
hip-hop anymore he says that that's and
that's my thing is it's like it's kind
of tough probably being hit because I
don't I don't necessarily I've never
looked at Adam as like a quote unquote
hip-hop head I think he's a guy who like
like is a fan of rap music who kind of
like fell into being a part of the
culture you know what I mean I think
he's just a very logical guy I mean yeah
for sure it's like he can pick up
anything and just have a logical answer
for it and he's a very good
conversationalist he's a great podcaster
and oh he's a businessman he'll see
something that's working he'll say let's
amplify this once it's not working no
more we moving on to this and he's had
some of the best hip-hop interviews ever
you know so kudos to him but if you're
like tired of chasing down like what's
hot on Soundcloud or I get it amazing
interviewer for sure he's great man yeah
right here though it's an interview he
right there I'm coming for uh coming I'm
coming for bootleg calf
hey man come on man you ain't white he
ain't gonna beef with you yeah I'm
coming for bootleg I'm rooting for y'all
man give me some of them damn artists
but they come here and tell them to come
over here to me let's share it when are
you guys launching the uh like the
actual like original shows I know you
guys said you're not rushing anything I
mean we were supposed to launch it uh
tomorrow right but I'm sitting here with
you you know I'm saying I have some
technical difficulties hooking up
cameras and wires and [__] but I I
rather I came here for you thank you
yeah I made sure I made it I made sure
to call if it don't come out today I
mean tomorrow I mean hopefully this week
if not next Wednesday yeah
why was that like black people on time
bro I had a rough morning yeah that's
crazy super rough morning my dates out
let me see let me see
I gotta get the [__] out of here too I
love you today super rough morning
um
the 29th if we don't do it by tomorrow
the 22nd it'll be it'll be out it'll be
the 29th it'll be the 29th yeah yeah is
this coming out tomorrow okay yeah so
perfect this is your Wednesday show for
the week guys yeah it's our Wednesday
show you I'm saying shout out to
everybody I'm saying shame on you I'm
saying got my boy 80 here we missing two
other [__] but yeah